OKAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
JOINING US FOR OUR REGULARLY
SCHEDULED TO BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS. A COMMITTEE
HEARING.
THE CHAIR NOTICES THE PRESENCE
OF A LEAST ONE REPUBLICAN MEMBER
ALSO WANTS TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. WELCOME A NEW
MEMBER OF OUR POSSESS
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AUTUMN OBERNOLTE WELCOME.
WE ALSO ARE JOINED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DINA SO WE WELCOME HIM AS
WELL.
HAVING SAID THAT'S.
DUE TO I'M SOMEONE WHO'S
SCHEDULING CONFLICTS WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY RIPON TO PRESENTING ON.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIX THIRTY
ONE FIFTY SEVEN A WHICH IS FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR.
WE HAVE ONE BILL RECOMMENDING
FOR CONSENT AND WE'LL GET TO
THAT ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM SO.
HAVING SAID THAT LET'S MOVE
ALONG ON THE FILE AND WILL GO IN
FILE I. ORDER A WHICH IS
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE BY SIMPLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL. SUMMER DONALD
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO JOIN US
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
AND AGAIN WHERE NOTING THAT WERE
OPERATING AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
A SUMMER DONALD WELCOME PLEASE
PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
.
I'M PLEASED TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FOUR FORTY FIVE WHICH REQUIRES
PET STORE OPERATORS TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS. WITH SPECIFIC
INFORMATION ABOUT THE ANIMALS
THEY ARE SELLING.
THIS BILL IS ABOUT PROVIDING
INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS NOT
REHASHING AB FORTY FORTY FIVE
FROM LAST YEAR.
AGAIN THIS IS A FOLLOW UP
MEASURE TO LAST YEAR'S EIGHTY
FOUR EIGHTY FIVE WHICH BEGINNING
IN TWENTY NINETEEN REQUIRES PET
STORE SELLING DOGS CATS. AND
RABBITS TO SOURCE THESE ANIMALS
FROM SHELTERS OR NONPROFIT.
RESCUE ORGANIZATIONS.
AB FORTY FIVE EXEMPTED PET
STORES FROM A NUMBER OF WARRANTY
LAWS WITH THE PROMISE TO WORK
CLOSELY WITH STAKEHOLDERS AND
RECAST THE PROVISIONS THE
FOLLOWING YEAR THIS YEAR.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE AS A
RESULT OF THIS PROMISE AND
SIMPLY INSURERS HAVE PET STORES
ARE STILL REQUIRED TO WRITE
CERTAIN INFORMATION TO CONSUMERS
PURCHASING ANIMALS. UNDER THE
FOR AB FORTY FIVE SALES MODEL.
THIS WILL ENSURE CLARITY FOR
BOTH PET STORE OPERATORS AND
CONSUMERS AS TO WHAT THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES ARE
WHEN PURCHASING COMPANION
ANIMALS IN CALIFORNIA PET
STORES.
AND I.
NOT SURE IF I HAVE A WITNESS YOU
I DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE ONE.
MISTER CHAIR I APOLOGIZE.
.
NO NOT NO APOLOGIES NECESSARY AS
A RECOGNITION THAT THERE IS AN
AYE AYE RECOMMENDATION ON THAT
KILL I HAVING SAID THAT ARE
THERE ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. OF
THIS BILL CNN ANY MEMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL.
SEEING NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AND YOUR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AT THIS
TIME. SEE NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COULD BE MEMBERS
SUMMER ROAD I DON'T DO WISH TO
CLOSE I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE IN MAY DOG BE
WITH YOU ALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ISN'T
O'DONNELL FOR.
PRESENTING THIS BILL.
SOME O'DONNELL WE ARE OPERATING
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE AND WILL TAKE
UP THIS BILL WHEN WE HAVE A
QUORUM. THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU.
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR.
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
AND YOU GET WILL PROVIDE UP TO
THREE MINUTES FOR WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT AND
THREE MINUTES FOR ONE SAYS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
ASSEMBLY OR QUIRK PLEASE PRESENT
WHATEVER RIGHT.
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS I
WANNA THANK COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH ME
CLOSELY ON THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY WILL ENSURE
THAT WARNINGS TO CONSUMERS ARE
PERMANENTLY PRINTED ON METALLIC
FILM. BALLOONS THESE BALLOONS
ARE EASILY RELEASED HIM COTTON
POWER LINES.
BECAUSE IN A POWERFUL ELECTRIC
DISK CHARGE CALLED FLASHOVER.
IN TWENTY THIRTEEN AND FIFTEEN
DOWNED WIRES FROM BALLOON
STRIKES IGNITED WILDFIRES.
SPURRING THOUSANDS OF ACRES.
I'M COMMITTED TO RESOLVE AS
POINTED OUT BY THE REPUBLICAN
STAFF THERE IS A CONFLICT WITH.
PENAL CODE AND THE CODE THAT WE
ARE CITING HOW WE WILL RESOLVE
THAT GOING FORWARD.
MY STAFF HAS WORKED CLOSELY
WITH BLOOM MANUFACTURERS
RETAILERS.
AND THEY HAVE NO PROBLEM WITH
THE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
.
WITH ME TODAY IS PATRICK WELCH
AND WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA MISS
BUT YOU TELL THESE ASSOCIATION
AND SEVERAL OTHERS.
THANK YOU.
.
PATRICK WHAT'S FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SWEETLY ASSOCIATION.
WE SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY IN SUPPORT
OF THE FAMILY MEMBERS PREVIOUS
EFFORTS AND APPRECIATE HIS
ONGOING WORK ON THIS ISSUE. IN
HERE TODAY JUST TO LET THE
COMMITTEE KNOW THIS IS A SERIOUS
ISSUE FOR UTILITIES AROUND THE
STATE. AND MYLAR BALLOONS DO
BECAUSE.
THOUSANDS OF OUTAGES EACH YEAR
AROUND THE STATE AND AND.
THIS IS A BILL THAT WE THINK
WILL HELP SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THANK YOU KAREN ELSE HAVE WITH
ME. MICHAEL MONAGHAN.
I'M LIKE A LOT OF IT WE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND COALITION
OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES
WE HAVE BEEN.
IN SUPPORT OF UP.
.
THIS EFFORT FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS I BELIEVE.
THERE ARE RISKS INVOLVED WITH
THESE BALLOONS OF FIRES AS WELL
AS RISK TO OUR EMPLOYEES THAT WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON.
WE SUPPORT BY AB TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY ON BECAUSE WE'VE RECEIVED
A NUMBER OF OUTAGES OF FIVE
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED SIXTY HAVE
OCCURRED IN OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY. OVER THE PAST SIX
YEARS IN OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
WE'VE RECEIVED A NUMBER OF SPOT
FIRES AND VEGETATION FIRES. IN
LAKE ELSINORE PARIS.
MEANT AN OUTAGE AND.
TORRANCE RENTALS PALS BURDENS
AREA THAT REALLY HEIGHTENS THE
NEED FOR NOT ONLY EDUCATION WE
ARE IN THE MIDDLE OF DOING. OUR
EDUCATION TO OUR SERVICE
TERRITORY MEMBERS THAT BEGINS
PRETTY MUCH AROUND THIS TIME OF
YEAR GOES THROUGH THE FALL AS
ALL THE KEY HOLIDAYS OF MEMORIAL
DAY FOURTH OF JULY LABOR DAY.
GRADUATIONS.
EVEN FEDERAL REUNIONS AND
WEDDINGS AND SO KNOWING THAT
THIS ISSUE IS A IS A IS A HIGH
PRIORITY FOR US FROM A SAFETY IN
A PUBLIC SAFETY ASPECT.
WE DO COMMAND OF THE SEVEN
MEMBER QUIRK FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
IN CHAMPION THIS ISSUE FOR THE
LAST FEW YEARS. AND WE ARE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR A BI TWENTY FOUR
FIFTY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK.
GOOD MORNING CARE ALSO BEHALF
THE CITY OF BURBANK WATER AND
POWER IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
AB MARK I'M HALF THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC POWER
AUTHORITY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
CNN ANY WITNESSES OR MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM CAN MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
I THINK YOU AND ONE OF THE MY
YOUR TENACITY MISTER QUIRK
BRINGING THIS BILL BACK IN
DIFFERENT ITERATIONS TIME AFTER
TIME.
.
SO.
SO DID THE OPPOSITION I MEAN WAS
IT JUST YOUR.
FANTASTIC NEGOTIATION POWERS
THAT HASN'T NOT ALL MY BALLOON
PEOPLE CALLING ME THIS TIME WHEN
THIS BILL COMES FORWARD OR HAS
THE INDUSTRY. ACKNOWLEDGES A
BIGGER PROBLEM ARE WILLING TO.%
TO HAVE TO COMPROMISE I'M JUST
FANTASTIC.
I WOULD CONCUR.
AT ASSEMBLY MEMBER OBERNOLTE.
LIKE THIS YEAR BECAUSE THE
DOCTOR BURKE THE BILL.
WOULD.
BAN THE MANUFACTURE. BALLOONS
HERE NOT THE CONSUMPTION OF THE
BALLOONS AND NOT THE PURCHASE OR
SALE OF THE BALLOONS. I'M JUST
CURIOUS HOW MANY WHAT WHAT WAS
THE RATIONALE AND BANNING
MANUFACTURING NOT THE OTHER
AVENUES
THE DISTRIBUTION AND HOW MANY OF
THESE BONDS ARE ACTUALLY
MANUFACTURED IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THE ISSUE FOR GOING WITH THE
MANUFACTURERS IS THAT TYPICALLY
THE DOLLAR STORES DON'T DO
ANYTHING. SO THERE IS A
REQUIREMENT WHICH.
A DOCTOR EGGMAN THIS.
THE MAYOR FOR TOWN. WILL MAKE
SURE THAT SHE'S GOT THESE
WEIGHTS ATTACHED
THE BALLOONS.
HE GO THE SAFE WHERE THE DOLLAR
STORE THEY DON'T BOTHER.
AND SO WE THINK IT'S A LOST
CAUSE TO WORK WITH THE
RETAILERS.
AND WE'RE HOPING WE CAN GET THE
MANUFACTURES TO DO THIS IT'S NOT
LIKE THIS IS A CALIFORNIA
PROBLEMS IS A NATIONAL PROBLEM.
BUT WE DON'T HAVE.
A NATIONAL CONGRESS ANYMORE
THAT PASSES FAILS SO.
WE JUST HAVE TO DO OUR BEST IN
CALIFORNIA DO YOU HAVE ANY DATA
ON HOW MANY OF THESE BALLOONS
ARE ACTUALLY MANUFACTURED IN
CALIFORNIA. THOUGHT SOMEONE
MIGHT.
OKAY SO CURRENT MANUFACTURERS IN
THE U. S. SO THERE'S NO BAND BY
THE WAY.
WHAT HAPPENS IS?
CURRENT. MANUFACTURERS IN
CALIFORNIA OR ANY HAVE IT.
THE PROBLEM IS.
IT BALLOONS COMING IN FROM
CHINA AND OTHER COUNTRIES. BUT
THERE'S NO I TRY TO BAN BEFORE
WHICH I THINK MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE.
BUT THAT BALLOON LOBBY YOU CAN'T
BEAT THEM.
NOT WERE TALK ABOUT THAT THE
WARNING LABEL RIGHT YEAH THIS
MORNING IS LIKE THIS BILL
REQUIRES A MORNING YEAH REQUIRES
SOME NOISE.
YOU FACTORED IN CALIFORNIA SUCH
WIVES CURIOUS ABOUT YOU KNOW
HOW.
HOW MANY OF THESE BONDS ARE
ACTUALLY MADE HERE SO IT SOUNDS
LIKE?
A FAIR NUMBER.
ALRIGHT WHAT WE TAKE UP ENOUGH
TIME WE CAN LOOK AT OR ABOUT THE
CHILD THOU TRYING GET NANCY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ABSOLUTELY ASSEMBLY WOMAN BAKER
THANK YOU I HAVE SIR A SIMILAR
QUESTION WHICH IS YEAH APOLOGIZE
I CAME A BIT LATE YOU MAY HAVE
COVERED THIS ALREADY. IF THEY
ARE MANUFACTURED OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA WILL THEY BE TREATED
THE SAME WAY AS MANUFACTURERS
INSIDE CALIFORNIA OR ARE THEY
TREATED DIFFERENTLY UNDER THE
SPELL BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING
IS THEY ARE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
UNDER THE SPELL.
CHECKING.
THAT WOULD BE ANOTHER WHEN WE
CAN YOU'RE RIGHT. YOU'RE RIGHT
IT'S TO MANUFACTURES A BALLOON
IN THE STATE IT IS.
.
A PROBLEM FOR PEOPLE OUTSIDE THE
STATE.
IF THE PROBLEM YEAH IT'S MY
PEOPLE THAT'S I DON'T TRY TO DO
INTERSTATE COMMERCE.
SO WE'RE TREATING WERE ONLY
ADDRESS IN OUR CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS BUT OTHERS WHO
MANUFACTURE THEM ELSEWHERE WILL
NOT HAVE THIS REQUIREMENT AND
THAT'S A PROBLEM.
I AGREE THANK YOU ARE YOU NOW
I'VE TRIED OTHER THINGS AND
GOVERNOR VETOES. OR WHATEVER SO.
WE'RE TRYING TO DO WHAT WE CAN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS TIME.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COURT DO YOU
WISH TO CLOSE.
I HOPE THIS IS THE LAST TIME I
BRING THIS STUFF.
THANK YOU FOR THAT CLOSE.
SOME OF IT OF COURSE.
I AM WITH THAT A SUMMER QUIRK
ABOUT WE ARE STILL OPERATING AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE SO WELL TAKE A
LOOK AT THE BILL AGAIN WHEN WE.
HAVE A QUORUM. HAPPENED SO THAT
WE'RE MOVE ON THEN TO ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS THE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SIXTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER.
THE SUMMER COOPER PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS.
GOOD MORNING.
KURT REGULATIONS MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO HOLD CANNABIS
INFORMATIONAL EDUCATIONAL
TRAINING EVENTS FOR STEPPING
CORPORATES PRODUCTS THAT
PARTISAN STRUCTURE.
THIS BILL STEMS FROM WE WANT TO
DO A TRAINING BECAUSE THE NEW
CANNABIS LAWS.
AFTER MEMBERS AND STAFF IN THE
BUILDING BUT THE WEIGHT LOSS
KILEY WRITTEN YOU CAN WE DO
TRAINING HERE. HELD EVENTS THAT.
STAY FAIRS OR ACT CULTURAL
EVENTS OBVIOUSLY PRECLUDES US.
AB THREE THIRTY SIXTY NINTH
WILL MAKE SOME EXEMPTIONS FOR
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES TO USE
PRODUCTS TO TRAIN EMPLOYEES
INCLUDING EMERGENCY WORKERS.
SOCIAL SERVICE STAFF AND FIRST
RESPONDERS.
AB THREE ZERO SIX NINE REQUIRE
THIS TRAINING MUST BE HELL FOR
EDUCATIONAL OR INFORMATIONAL
PURPOSES.
THE VIC NOT BE ACCEPTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC.
IN THE BILL PURPOSES SELF
CONSUMPTION PROVIDING CANADA
SAMPLES AT THE EVENT.
I DO FEEL THE TEARS AMENDMENTS
ARE STEP WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING I WAS GONNA SAY
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS MELANIE CLEAR THIS WITH
THE CAN ON A CRUISE COMPANY ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY CANNABIS
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION.
AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER HAD
STATED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
COLLABORATED WITH THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TO HOST AN EDUCATIONAL
AND HERE IN THE CAPITAL WHERE
MEMBERS OF OUR ASSOCIATION
BROUGHT AND LABELS. AND
EDUCATIONAL MATERIALS DISPLAYS
AND PRODUCTS RATE RANGING FROM.
COOKIES AND BROWNIES TO BE PANS
AND TINCTURES AND BUSINESS
OWNERS ARE ALSO ON HAND TO TALK
WITH MEMBERS AND STAFF ABOUT
MANUFACTURING PROCESSES LABELING
PROCESSES. AND INDUSTRY ISSUES
THE EVENT WAS VERY WIDELY
ATTENDED BY BOTH MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND MANY ACTUALLY CONFIDED
TO US THAT THIS WAS. THEIR FIRST
TIME SEEING CANNABIS PRODUCTS IN
REAL.
I FOUND THEM VERY HELPFUL AND
THIS YEAR WHEN WE TRIED TO HOLD
ANOTHER ONE WE FOUND THAT OUR
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW
DISALLOWED US FROM DOING SO. AND
UNDER CURRENT REGULATIONS THERE
IS A CANNABIS EVENT LICENSE AND
ME AND CAMPUS EVENTS MAY ONLY BE
HELD BY PERSONS WHO HAVE BEEN
ISSUED A CAMPUS EVENTS ORGANIZER
LICENSE BUT THIS LICENSE TYPE IS
INTENDED FOR THE LARGE SCALE.
SALES IN CONSUMPTION EVENTS AND
THAT YOU SEE ON COUNTY
FAIRGROUNDS SUCH AS THE HIGH
TENS OF AND HERE IS OUR COMMON
OVER THE WEEKEND.
AND THE LACK OF CLARITY AND LEAD
US TO BELIEVE THAT WE COULDN'T
HOLD THIS. EVENT FOR POLICY
MAKERS THIS YEAR AND SO IT'S OUR
BELIEF THAT THESE EVENTS ARE NOT
ONLY HOPEFUL BUT ESSENTIAL IN
REGULATING AFRAID YOU
MARKETPLACE. AND WE THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER FOR
CAMPING THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU IMAGE ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK AND.
I GOOD MORNING KIDDING APE ON
BEHALF OF WE DROP CANNABIS
DELIVERY AND SUPPORT THE.
HELLO ALISON BROWN DIRECTOR OF
GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS FOR EASE
SOLUTIONS INC ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THIRTY SIXTY NINE THINK YOU.
DANIEL CONWAY ON BEHALF OF TRUTH
ENTERPRISES IN OUR LICENSE
BRANDS AND BUSINESSES IN
SUPPORT.
RICH MILLER ON BEHALF AMERICAN
ALLIANCE FOR MEDICAL CANNABIS IN
SUPPORT.
I NEED TO XIN WITNESSES WISHING
TO SPEAK
SUPPORT.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT ANY
WITNESSES WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING THEIR OWN MEMBERS THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS.
TIME FOR.
SOME OF COOPER SEE NO QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FOR THE AUTHOR. AS
IMMIGRANT JEWISH TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND AGAIN WE
ARE ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE IN
THE MILK.
VISIT THIS BILL WHEN WE HAVE A
COURT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A
MACABRE.
AB MEMBERS WE HAVE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR AND FIVE
LEFT TO FOR I'LL ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IS A CONSENT.
ACCOUNT THERE ITEM AND ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WE ARE JUST WAITING
FOR. AN AUTHOR TO PRESENT AND WE
ARE. LACKING ONE ADDITIONAL
MEMBER TO. MAKE A QUORUM SO AT
THIS POINT WE ARE NOW CALLING
FOR. THE AUTHOR TO PRESENT ON
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR
I STARTED.
THE PROBLEM.
BUT IT.
EVERY.
DIDN'T MEMBERS THAT WE IS THAT I
NOW HAVE THE PRESENCE OF A OF
SUB THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR
WOULD FOR. ACCOMMODATING THEIR
REQUESTS TO PRESENT ON FILE ITEM
NUMBER FOUR WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US PLEASE FEEL FREE TO PRESENT
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
MUCH.
THEY VARIAS THAT EVERY DAY THAT
THE THIRD STRINGER GETS TO COME
IN AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TO YOU
FOLKS SO. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN VERSA SO THANK YOU FOR
THE UPDATE PREVENT TO PREVENT.
WOW FOR PA.
HOW CLEARLY NOT EXPECTING THIS
THIS MORNING SO?
TO PRESENT AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN AND FOR THE WORK THAT YOU
AND YOUR STAFF TO PUT INTO THIS
MEASURE. I'M PROBABLY WORKING ON
THIS BIPARTISAN EFFORT WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE TODAY.
MISTER LACKEY MISTER BONTA.
BUT I'D ALSO LIKE TO START UP A
SCENE THAT WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON PAGE
THIRTEEN OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH
WOULD ALLOW. FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER RESORTING BACK TO
THE ORIGINAL TAXES PRIOR TO JUNE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WAS BILL
SCHEDULED TO SUNSET IF WE ARE
NOT MEETING THE ANNUAL REVENUES
TO ADEQUATELY IN FUND AT AGENCY
COSTS AS WELL AS PROGRAMS
ENVISIONED UNDER PROP SIXTY
FOUR.
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY.
AND I AM I'M.
NOT MY NOT SO YOU UNDERSTAND
OKAY OKAY. NOW HAVE WORKED
CLOSELY THE CATHOLIC.
AS FELLOW.
PHILIP JOINT AUTHORS OF THE
MEDICAL CANNABIS RATE THAT BIG
STATE REGULATORY SAFETY ACT. WE
ALONG WITH OUR COLLEAGUES
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WOULD. COOLEY
JONES SAWYER LACKEY BONTA.
HAVE BELIEVE IN CALIFORNIA WERE
CANNABIS.
LAWS.
PROTECT THAT THE PUBLIC IN
CHILDREN PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT
INSURE SAFE PRODUCTS AND COME
BACK THE ILLEGAL THE ILLICIT
MARKET.
IN RESPONSE THE ILLICIT MARKET
WE NEED TO.
WE NEED TO PASS THIRTY AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY SEVEN WHICH WILL
CREATE A THREE YEAR WINDOW TO
TRANSITION CONSUMERS FROM THE
ILLEGAL CANNABIS SO SELLERS OF
CANNABIS. TO LAWFULLY REGULATED
MARKETPLACE LET'S BE CLEAR
CALIFORNIA'S REGULATED CANNABIS
MARKETPLACE IS STILL IN ITS
INFANCY. THEIR SIGNIFICANT START
UP COSTS FACING THE GOOD ACTORS
THOSE BUSINESSES THAT WANT TO
COMPLY WITH THE LAW AND DO
BUSINESS THE RIGHT WAY. THIS
GOODNESS IS GOOD BUSINESS WILL
NOT BE ABLE TO COMPETE AGAINST
ILLICIT MARKET IF THEY CANNOT BE
COMPETITIVE ON PRICE.
CALIFORNIA CURRENTLY LEVELS AN
ESTIMATED FORTY FIVE PERCENT TAX
ON COMPLIANT ACTORS.
WE'VE SEEN THE STRATEGY OF OF
TEMPORALLY DRIVE TEMPORARILY
TILING BACK CERTAIN TAXES.
THEY ACTUALLY PAY HUGE DIVIDENDS
IN THE FORM OF HIGHER TAX
REVENUES IN THE LONG RUN. BOTH
OREGON AND WASHINGTON OF
SIMPLIFIED TO REDUCE THEIR TAX
RATES AND HAVE SEEN TACK THIS
STATE TAX REVENUE INCREASE AS
BUSINESSES PROSPER.
FOR EXAMPLE WHEN WASHINGTON
LOWERED ITS TAXES WITHIN A JUST
A FEW MONTHS OF LEGALIZATION.
REVENUE GREW FROM THIRTEEN POINT
FOUR MILLION IN JUNE OF TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN TO THIRTY THREE
MILLION IN APRIL TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN. ONCE THE LEGAL MARKET
PLACES ESTABLISH ITS ROOTS NO
PUN INTENDED.
THE TAX RATES WILL RETURNS THE
PRESCRIBED LEVELS.
SET IN PROP SIXTY FOUR AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN IS
IMPORTANT STEP TO ENSURE THAT WE
PROTECT LEGITIMATE TAXPAYING
BUSINESSES. AND STOP THE ILLEGAL
BLACK MARKET IN CALIFORNIA THAT
WITNESSES ARE WITH US TODAY.
JOIN US AMY JENKINS A
CALIFORNIA CANNABIS INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION AND ALSO THE WITHOUT
ABERNATHY A PRESENT.
OF ARC VIEW.
WHO DOES NOT HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT CAN
PRIDE TECHNICAL IS THIS
ASSISTANCE ON THE CALIFORNIA
CAMPUS MARKET? THANK YOU FOR
YOUR. INDULGENCE.
THE CHAIR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AGAIN DOCTOR WOULD FOR SCORING
ON OVER HERE AND I PRESENTING
THIS IN ACCOMMODATING THIS
COMMITTEE WILL POTS FOR JUST ONE
MOMENT TO SUBSEQUENTLY SECRET.
LOW HERE. BRO. ARAMBULA. BAKER.
LITTLE.
CHEN.
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM.
EGGMAN
FONG. GIPSON. GRAYSON.
HOLDEN.
IRWIN.
MEDINA.
MULLIN.
OBERNOLTE.
TING.
IT AGAIN JUST MEMBERS NOW THAT
THE MATCH NUMBERS TEN AT A GIVEN
THE ARE OF WONDERFUL ADDITIONS
TO THIS COMMITTEE.
PLEASE.
YOU MY FRIENDS ABERNATHY FROM.
WE ARE FREE GROUP BENT THERE ARE
FEW MARKET RESEARCH.
.
CALIFORNIA IS NOT LIKE MOST OF
THE STATES THAT WE'VE SEEN.
COME ONLINE WITH.
ADULT USE.
SO FAR.
.
WE HAVE BY FAR THE MOST
SOPHISTICATED.
ILLICIT MARKET IN THE COUNTRY.
WE.
DEALT WITH.
VERY LOOSE
REGULATIONS FOR TWENTY YEARS AND
BUSINESSES THAT WERE.
LEGAL UNDER.
THAT THE LOOSE MEDICAL
REGULATIONS PRIOR TO JANUARY
ONE.
OF MANY OF THEM ARE NOW ON THE
LIST SIDE OF THE BUSINESS SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT.
WHAT WE'RE REALLY TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT
DISPENSARIES COMPETING WITH?
JUST
YOU KNOW THAT ROOMMATE FROM
COLLEGE OR THAT DAY SHADY STREET
DEALER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AT.
LICENSED REGULATED BUSINESSES
COMPETING WITH.
AND MANY CASES SHOPS THAT TO
THE CONSUMER LOOK.
VIRTUALLY IDENTICAL TO THOSE
LICENSED AND REGULATED
BUSINESSES DELIVERY SERVICES
THAT LOOK AND FEEL. LIKE LICENSE
IN REGULATED BUSINESSES.
I'VE BEEN TO MANY OF THESE
PLACES SINCE JANUARY ONE AND.
THE ONLY INDICATION THAT YOU'D
HAVE THAT. OF THESE PLACES ARE
IN BACK NOT LICENSED AND
REGULATED IS LOOKING AT.
THE PRICE THAT YOU PAY WHEN YOU
WALK OUT THE DOOR AND THE LACK
OF.
TAXES BEING COLLECTED.
.
WELL THAT OVERALL DEMAND FOR
CANNABIS IS RELATIVELY
INELASTIC.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT MARKETS THAT
HAVE BOTH.
LEGAL AND ILLICIT CHANNELS FOR
ACQUISITION.
THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF PRICE
ELASTICITY.
SO AS THE PRICE GOES UP IN LEGAL
CHANNELS IT FORCES MORE AND MORE
OF THE BUSINESS AT TWO.
A. ILLEGAL CHANNELS WHEN WE LOOK
AT THE THE WHOLESALE TAX.
.
OF NINE THAT NINE DOLLARS
INCLUDING FIVE CENTS PER OUNCE.
IT'S ONE THING TO SAY NINE
DOLLARS AND TWENTY FIVE CENTS
PER OUNCE BUT THAT HAPPENS AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE SUPPLY
CHEN AND THAT TAX GETS
COMPOUNDED OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
DOWN THE SUPPLY CHAIN AS
DIFFERENT PARTIES I'D TAKE THEIR
MARGINS AND AS A.
TAXES GET LEVY.
SO ULTIMATELY BETWEEN.
.
THE THE NINE.
TWENTY FIVE.
PER OUNCE TAX AND THE
ADDITIONAL COST OF TESTING
CANNABIS.
THAT.
REAL ESTATE ARTS ARE THAT THE
RETAIL EXCISE TAX.
.
AS WAS CALIFORNIA SALES TAX.
AND THE ADDITIONAL NEED FOR A
DISTRIBUTOR TO POLL MARGIN.
WE'RE LOOKING AT A A SEVENTY
SEVEN PERCENT PREMIUM.
UNKEPT.
WITH THAT WHAT ONE MINUTE LEFT.
I'M ON CANVASES PURCHASED
THROUGH A.
LICENSED AND REGULATED
DISPENSARIES.
.
THAT GOES UP DRAMATICALLY IS THE
PULSE UP PRICES CANNABIS GOES
DOWN THOSE CALCULATIONS ARE
BASED ON A FOURTEEN HUNDRED
DOLLAR POUND PRICE FOR CANNABIS.
AND IT'S A VERY.
.
IT'S VERY LIKELY THAT WE'LL SEE
SUB SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLAR POUND.
CANNABIS OF THIS THIS BURDEN
REALLY DOES MAKE IT A VERY VERY
DIFFICULT FOR.
.
FOR LEGAL.
BUSINESSES AND SET A CALIFORNIA
TO COMPETE.
WE'LL SEE SOME GROWTH.
WHETHER OR NOT THIS BILL PASSES
BUT WE'LL SEE A LOT MORE GROWTH.
.
IF IT DOESN'T WAS TO EXPECTING
A.
WE EXPECT TWENTY NINE PERCENT.
AS IS A COMPOUND ANNUAL GROWTH
RATE OVER THE NEXT THREE YEARS.
IF WE COULD SPLIT THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THAT AND COLORADO'S
GROWTH RATE IN ITS FIRST THREE
YEARS OF ADULT USE.
WE WOULD SEE A ATTEMPT POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR MARKET IN
TWENTY TWO ANYWAY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK EDITION ALL
COMMENTS IT JUST DOESN'T NEED
TO.
YES I'LL BE BRIEF AS CHAIRMAN
LOW MEMBERS A MEETING CAN
SOMEBODY HAVE OF THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THIS IS OUR OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY BILL. I'M OUR OPERATORS
NEED A PATH TO COMPLIANCE AND
OUR EXISTING COMPLAIN OPERATORS
I NEED TO HAVE THE BURDENS EASED
ON THEM SO THAT THEY CAN
CONTINUE TO COMPLY IN OUR
MARKETPLACE.
HOW DO YOU VERY MUCH WELCOME
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES VISION INTEGRATE IN
SUPPORT JUST NAME AFFILIATION IF
YOU WISH TO DO SO?
GOOD MORNING ELEANOR TEAS ON
BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT THINK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS JEAN HURST HERE TODAY ON
BEHALF OF THE RIVERSIDE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CASEY O'CONNOR BEHALF
OF BOARD OF EQUALIZATION VICE
CHAIR FIONA MONSTER ON SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
ACTUALLY LOCKER WITH NAS MEN ON
BEHALF OF THE MODERATE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MAP BROUGHT
ON BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI ALLISON BROWNIE SOLUTIONS IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TRACY STEVENS
REPRESENTING SO NEVA ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING KIDDING ME BOBBIE
AFTER WE DROPPED CANNABIS
SLAVERY IN THE LONG BEACH
COLLECTORS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING JASON BRIAN TO BE
HAVE THE CALIFORNIA GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING AIR NORWOOD ON
BEHALF OF THE CANNABIS SUSPICION
ASSOCIATION ALSO INSTRUCTS
IKEA.
BEN WE WANNA BE HALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SPENDING CHAMBERS OF
COMMERCE AND THE CALIFORNIA
BLACK CHAMBER OF COMMERCE GRANT
AND BEHALF OF SPORT THINKING.
GOOD MORNING MELANIE GREIVIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CAMPUS
MANUFACTURES ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
DANIEL CONWAY ATRUTH
ENTERPRISES IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MEXICO US ON BEHALF OF THE
CALPERS CHEMIST LOW RELIANCE
INFOCOM AND SUPPORT.
RICH WELL ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN ALLIANCE MEDICAL
CANNABIS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DRILL COOK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURING TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ARE LETTER IS
FORTHCOMING WE'RE IN SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF CMG KALILA AND BLACK
PER LOGISTICS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
MARIN PANETTA WITHIN THAT IT HAS
BUSINESS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT AT THIS TIME.
SEE NO ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT NOW
LIKE TO CALL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. OF.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO COME UP TO
THE.
TABLE AND WILL ALLOW UP TO THREE
MINUTES FOR WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
SPEAK WHATEVER READY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
COMMITTEE MY NAME'S GOING ABOUT
THIS AND I REPRESENT DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE.
DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE IS A
NATIONAL NONPROFIT DEDICATED TO.
REDUCING THE HARMS RELATED WITH
DRUGS TO DRUGS AND HARMS RELATE
PROHIBITION AND IT'S
INCARCERATIONS.
RELATED TO DRUG USE.
OUR SEE FOR PARTNER. DRUG POLICY
ACTION WAS THE SECOND LARGEST
DONOR TO PROP SIXTY FOUR AND WE
WERE PARTICIPATED IN THE
DRAFTING OF PROP FIFTY.
WE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE THAT WE GREATLY RESPECT
THE AUTHORS. WE HAVE PROPOSES
MEASURES PREMATURE.
THE BALLOT MEASURE WAS DISCUSSED
DEBATED AND ANALYZED IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN.
THE LA NO OUR OWN STATE LA NO.
DID AN INDEPENDENT ANALYSIS OF
WHAT THE TAXES MEANT
WHAT THE MARKET WOULD BEAR WHAT
WAS THE EXPERIENCE OF THE
MARKET.
THEY SPOKE TO NUMEROUS EXPERTS
HAD AT INDEPENDENT NOT INDUSTRY
RELATED BUT INDEPENDENT
ANALYSTS.
DOPPLER ALICE'S NEAR ALICE'S WAS
THAT WHEN THE MARKET WAS MATURE
THIS WOULD BRING IN UPWARDS OF A
BILLION DOLLARS OR MORE. IN
STATE AND LOCAL REVENUE.
ALSO IN THE ACT.
WE MANDATE THAT THE LA I'LL DO
ANOTHER ANALYSIS BASED ON THE
FIRST YEAR HALF OR SO. OF THE
CALIFORNIA EXPERIENCE.
AND MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND THE
LEGISLATURE ABOUT HOW TO ADJUST
THE TAX.
AND IN THE ACT IT SAYS VERY
CLEARLY. THAT THESE ARE THE
MEASURES FOR DECIDING THAT.
HOW TO UNDERCUT THE BLACK
MARKET?
HOW TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
PRODUCT IS NOT ATTRACTIVE TO
MINORS?
AND PEOPLE UNDER TWENTY ONE.
AND TO MAKE SURE THE REVENUE
COMES IN FOR THE THINGS THAT THE
VOTERS MANDATED.
THE VOTERS ALSO HAD A VIOLENT
TWENTY SIXTEEN AS DID THE LA
ELLEN.
THE PRESSING WAS DEBATED. WHAT
WOULD THE MONEY BE SPENT ON SO
THE MONEY IS EARMARKED FOR
REGULATION AS YOU KNOW?
INVESTMENT IN LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES MOST IMPACTED BY THE
DRUG WAR INVESTMENT IN DRUG
TREATMENT FOR YOUTH AND YOUNG
ADULTS.
INVESTMENT ENVIRONMENTAL
RESTORATION AND.
PROTECTION.
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WE ARE CONCERNED THAT THIS.
EARLY ACTION SUPPORTED BY THE
INDUSTRY NOT SURPRISING THAT
EVERY INDUSTRY WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE THEIR TAXES CUT.
THE SONGS WERE ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY OUR CONCERNS ARE WHAT
FUTURE WE DON'T HAVE THE DATA
AND THAT'S THE JOB OF THE ONLY.
TO COLLECT THAT DATA AND GIVE
ASIDE ANALYSIS.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THERE'S
POTENTIAL DANGERS.
THE CHOICE OF HIGH TAXES COMES
FROM OUR EXPERIENCE OF ALCOHOL
AND TOBACCO.
THE RESEARCH ON ALCOHOL AND
TOBACCO IS CLEAR.
YOU KEEP THE PRICES ARTIFICIALLY
HIGH.
SO IT'S LESS ATTRACTIVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT'S TRUE FOR BEER IT'S
RIVER LECTER EXTRA FOR
CIGARETTES SURLY CIGARETTES ARE
FAR MORE TAXING CANNABIS.
BUT WE DO THAT FOR A REASON.
NOT MAINLY AND PRIMARILY
REVENUE.
IT'S TO DETER YOUNG PEOPLE THE
STATISTICAL EVIDENCE IS THAT
YOUNG PEOPLE DO RESPOND TO PRICE
TAG.
PRICES GO UP YOUNG PEOPLE LESS
LIKELY CONSUME.
I MAKE WITH MY COLLEAGUES TO
SPEAK.
BUT. TEN SECONDS LEFT.
TEN SECONDS ROBERT.
THE BILL.
MY NAME IS ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
ADDICTION MEDICINE.
WHO TOOK PART THEN TO PAST
PRESIDENTS LED THAT NEWSOME TASK
FORCE WHAT THE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR TREATMENT?
AND.
THEY HAD HIM PUT MATT NEVER
LANGUAGES FOR THAT THE IN THE
TREATMENT LANGUAGE OF THE
INITIATIVE WE THINK IT'S TOTALLY
PREMATURE TO DO THIS WE THINK IT
COULD HAVE EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE
EFFECT OF WHAT.
THE SPECULATIVE AND THESE ARE
SPECULATIVE PER.
.
IDEAS OF MORE MORE REVENUE IT'S
KIND LIKE IF TO USE CAR EIGHT
ZERO AND I'M A FEW. MONTHS OKAY
DOT OF THAT'S A MUCH APPRECIATED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
SINGLE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS
TIME.
YEAH DOT ORG.
I THINK THAT AND NUMBER CAN BE A
LONG MILE AND A QUESTION I KNOW
YOU'RE PINCHING TODAY MISTER
DOCTOR WOULD. UP BUT THIS IDEA
OF OF PRE MATURITY.
.
THE MAY REVISE BECOMING OUT WE
WILL SEE WHAT THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
ARE WHAT WHY THE RUSH.
WELL I THINK I THINK YOU'RE
GONNA SEE THE ACTUAL NUMBER TO
REVENUE NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY
LOWER SIGNIFICANTLY LOWER THAN
PROJECTED AND I THINK THAT IS
BECAUSE IS PARTLY BECAUSE OF THE
TAX BURDEN ITSELF.
THIS IS A VERY EXPENSIVE
INDUSTRY I THINK TO GET STARTED
AND.
THE LICENSE FEES ARE VERY HIGH.
LOCAL LOCALS HAVE ADDED ON
TAXES AS WELL WITH THE YOUR
COUNTIES OR CITIES.
SO YOU'VE TAKEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE
THAT ARE THAT ARE PAIN AND I
DON'T THINK IT IS THE MISTER
LACKEYS NOTES HERE NINE
EXAGGERATION FORTY FIVE PERCENT
TAX BURDEN. ADD TO THAT THE FACT
THAT THESE BUSINESSES CANNOT
DEDUCT NORMAL BUSINESS EXPENSES
LIKE.
WAGES UTILITIES BECAUSE OF A
FEDERAL TAX CALL CALLED TO
EIGHTY E.. DOESN'T ALLOW THEM TO
DO THAT OUR STATE FOLLOWS THAT
AS WELL SO THE TAX BURDEN IS
ACTUALLY POTENTIALLY MUCH HIGHER
THAN THAT. AND I THINK THAT SOME
PLAYERS IN THE IN THE IN THE
MARKET ARE JUST SIMPLY SAYING.
WELL I'M I'M JUST I'M JUST NOT
READY TO GO THERE YET AND SO WE
ARE NOT SEEN THE NUMBER OF
BUSINESSES COME FORWARD I
BELIEVE THAT WE THOUGHT WERE
GOING TO AND WE'RE NOT SEEING
THE REVENUE COMING IN FOR THE
TAXES AND SO. SO I WOULD AGREE
WITH MISTER BACCHUS THAT THAT
THAT THE IDEA WAS THAT AT A
POINT WE WOULD HAVE A ROBUST
MARKET WITH A BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR IN TAX REVENUE. BUT I THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE THAN THE
ACTUAL NUMBERS IN THE FIRST
QUARTER ARE WOEFULLY.
WOEFULLY BELOW THE PROJECTIONS
AND I THINK THAT'S A CHALLENGE
AND SO WHEN THE LEDGE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SIXTEEN.
WE WERE ACTUALLY.
WORKING ON ON TAX NUMBERS.
AND ADDS THAT WAS WORKING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE THOSE
NUMBERS WERE ACTUALLY LOWER THAN
WHAT IS IN THE INITIATIVE NOW.
AND.
BECAUSE WE LEARNED I THINK WE
LEARNED.
FROM THE INDUSTRY.
AND THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
BALANCE BALANCE.
REPEAL THE TAX REVENUE IN THE
TAX BURDEN SO.
THAT'S THAT IS. THAT IS HOW I
SEE IT I DON'T I.
YOU KNOW IN A PERFECT WORLD IT
WOULD IT WOULD BE NICE IF WE HAD
HAD THE ABILITY AS A AS A AS A
BODY TO ESTABLISH THE REVENUE
THAT THE. THE OF THE ACTUAL
ATTACKS LEVELS BUT WE DON'T AND
THAT'S PART OF THE STATUTE
ITSELF. BUT I AS I DON'T THINK
ITS REPORT PREMATURE.
IF WE WANT IF WE IF OF OUR GOAL
AND THAT'S WHERE THAT'S WHERE WE
ARE AS AUTHORS. IS TO COME BACK
THE ILLICIT MARKET BRING
EVERYBODY TO REGULATE
ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO MAKE IT
FAIR.
AND I THINK THAT.
FORTY FIVE PERCENT IS PRETTY
TOUGH ON TOP OF THE FACT THAT
YOU NOW HAVE. THE INABILITY TO
DEDUCT NORMAL BUSINESS EXPENSES
AT A FEDERAL AND STATE LEVEL THE
TAX BURDEN.
IT GOES WAY BEYOND FORTY FIVE
PERCENT OF THAT POINT.
DO YOU FEEL LIKE THAT WAS.
TAKEN INTO ACCOUNT WITH THE
INITIATIVE.
I I THINK THAT.
.
DID THE VOTERS SUPPORTED.
I.
IT WAS A SIXTY FOUR PAGE
INITIATIVE THERE'S A LOT OF
INFORMATION THERE I THINK THAT
THE PUBLIC CLEARLY WANTED.
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE ISSUES
DECRIMINALIZATION THE ABILITY
FOR ADULT USE I THINK PEOPLE
REALIZE THAT WAS A LIE DETAIL IN
THAT IN THAT INITIATIVE AND.
YOU KNOW.
I.
DID YOU ALL READ THE SIXTY FOUR
PAGES.
I DON'T BELIEVE PEOPLE DEAD
SOUTH AND AND SO I THINK IT'S I
THINK PART OF OUR JOB IS A
LEGISLATURE'S TO HELP.
HELP IMPLEMENT THINKS I BELIEVE
THIS ACTUALLY WILL IN TIME.
ALLOW US TO GET TO A POINT WILL
WE WILL BE ABLE TO REALIZE THAT
BILLION DOLLARS.
BUT WE NEED TO DO IT AND OUT IN
A THOUGHTFUL WAY THINK.
AND IF THEN IF THE NUMBERS COME
OUT I MAY REVISE THAT ARE THAT
ARE CLOSER TO PROJECTION.
THEN I'D BE SURPRISED.
LOW WILL THE BILL CONTINUE TO
MOVE FORWARD.
.
WELL I AND THE THIRD.
PICK ON THE PINCH HITTER THAT
CAN YOU.
I GOT BETTER MIGHT ASK HIM BUT.
BUT BUT I WITH.
IT AND IF I IF I MIGHT.
DOCTOR EDMUND FOR THE BENEFIT
OF HAVING A SUMMER BONTA PRESENT
THE QUESTION WAS ABOUT.
DID DO YOU BELIEVE THAT THIS
BILL MIGHT BE PREMATURE A GIVEN
THE TIMING AND THE UNCERTAINTY
GIVEN SOME OF THE PROJECTIONS
AND SO PERHAPS YOU MIGHT BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO THE DOCTOR IT MEANS
QUESTIONS AND GIVING. ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION.
YEAH I THINK U. CELLO THANK YOU
DOCTOR WOULD AFTER STEP IN AND
IT THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN AND
AND THE WHOLE.
.
COMMITTEE FREE FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS AND YOUR ENGAGE IN ON
US.
AS THE ISSUE OF PROP SIXTY FOUR
IBUT WHAT THE VOTERS VOTED FOR
WAS A LEGALIZED REGULATED
MARKET.
AND IT'S EITHER A LOT OF.
ASSUMPTIONS THAT THAT WENT INTO
WHAT KIND OF REVENUE WOULD COME
OUT AT IT WHAT THAT IT MIGRATION
FROM THAT.
ILLICIT MARKET THE BLACK AND
GREY MARKET THE LEGACY MARKET AS
SOME PEOPLE CALL IT TO THAT
REGULATED MARKET WOULD BE. AND
WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW THAT'S
NOT HAPPENING.
AND YOU'RE ONE IS SO CRITICAL
FOR FOR THE TRANSITION WERE WERE
JUST IN THE FIRST FEW MONTHS OF
ARE REGULATED MARKET AND WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT AS MANY.
INDUSTRY MEMBERS ARE MOVING OVER
TO TO THE REGULATED MARKET BEING
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS LIKE ANY
OTHER BUSINESS PAYING THEIR
TAXES CREATING GOOD JOBS.
AND IT'S JUST NOT HAPPENING.
AND.
SORT OF COUNTER INTUITIVELY IF
YOU LOWER THE TAX RATE.
YOU CAN INCREASE THE TAX REVENUE
AND THAT'S NOT JUST A
HYPOTHETICAL ACADEMIC.
PROPOSITION THAT'S WHAT WE SAW
HAPPEN IN THE STATE OF
WASHINGTON IN THE STATE OF
OREGON.
SO WE BELIEVE THAT THIS WILL
HAVE TO BE A WIN WIN IN THAT IT
CAN GENERATE MORE REVENUE BY
LOWER THE TAX RATE AND HAVING
MORE TAX PAYERS COME OVER. TO
THE REGULATED MARKET NUMBER ONE.
AND.
NUMBER TO HELPING ROUTE OUT AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THAT THAT
ILLICIT MARKET.
AT WHICH WHICH UNDERCUTS THE
REGULATED MARKET AND HELPS GIVE
THE VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA WHAT
THEY WANTED LEGAL REGULATED
MARKET SO I MEAN IS IS.
IS A LOT OF THIS.
YOU KNOW.
OUR WORD WHAT WORD TRYING TO DO
WITH THE BEST INFORMATION THAT
WE HAVE AVAILABLE YES IS IT IS
IT A GUARANTEED EXACT SCIENCE I
CAN PROMISE YOU.
IT IT'S OCCURRING EXACTLY THAT
VOTE THE WAY WERE SAYING.
I DIDN'T KNOW I WE DO THAT ALL
THE TIME THAT WITH OUR BILLS WE
TRIED IT WITH THEM WITH
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE WE TRY
TO CREATE THE BEST POLICY. AND
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO ADJUST TO
BE NIMBLE TO WHAT'S HAPPENING OR
IN THIS CASE NOT HAPPENING WHICH
IS.
.
NOT ENOUGH PEOPLE MOVING OVER TO
THE RATED MARKETPLACE SO WE
THINK THIS IS A A A. A PRO.
LEGALIZED AND REGULATED REGIME
BILL THAT CAN ACTUALLY GENERATE
MORE REVENUE BUT WERE OPEN TO
THE POSSIBILITY THAT.
YOU KNOW IT IT.
TRY TRY TO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE REVENUE IS.
BOB AT AND WHERE IT'S GOING AND
AND AND TO THE PEOPLE THAT IT IT
SUPPORTING THAT THEY'VE REMAIN
WHOLE THIS IS NOT.
AT ALL AND AN ATTEMPT TO DEPRIVE
ANYONE OF REVENUE THAT THEY
SOUGHT THE RIGHT NOW THE REVENUE
THEY EXPECTED. IS IS NOT
HAPPENING
I IS NOT COMING AND WE THINK IT
IT'S MORE LIKELY TO WITH THIS
PROPOSAL.
GOOD TO THE QUESTION WHAT AGAIN
THOUGH IF IF.
IF AFTER THAT MAYBE IF IT LOOKS
LIKE THINGS ARE NOT AS NOT AS
DIRE AS YOU'RE YOU'RE
SUGGESTING.
WILL THE BILL CONTINUE MOVE
FORWARD.
IT I AM I THINK WE HAVE TO BE
OPEN TO NEW INFORMATION BUT
EFFORT COME WHATEVER MAY BE IF
IF WE SEE IN MAY THAT.
REVENUES ARE STRONG AND ILLICIT
MARKET IS IS IS SHRINKING AT A
RATE THAT'S THAT THAT IS.
CONSISTENT WITH WHAT OUR
EXPECTATIONS ARE.
AND THAT ARE BILL THIS IS NO
LONGER NECESSARY OF OF COURSE
THAT NEW INFORMATION WILL BE
RELEVANT TO WHAT WE DO WITH THE
BILL GOING FORWARD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER
CHAD.
THANK YOU MISTER THIS QUESTIONS
US FOR THE OPPOSITION.
AND MY QUESTIONS THEIR OF ID
CHECKS.
RIGHT NOW WHAT IS THE PROCESS
FOR ILLICIT SELLERS.
IF THE AREA IN WHICH THERE
INTEREST IN AREAS LIKE THERE'S
A.
A MINOR. WOULD HAVE ID CHECKS.
DO IF ANY RIGHT NOW ARE
CURRENTLY.
THE PRESENT.
THE BALLOT MEASURE PROVIDES FOR
REVENUE FOR REGULATION ACROSS
THE NUMBER OF SECTORS IN THOSE
INCLUDE EXPLICITLY THAT WE WANT
IT IN THE BALLOT MEASURE THE
SIXTY FOUR PAGES THAT WERE
MENTIONED INCLUDE.
DO THE SAME THING WE DO FOR
ALCOHOL WHICH IS CENTERED UNDER
AGE.
THE UNDER TWENTY ONE PERSON INTO
A SPACE TO SEE IF THEY CAN
PURCHASE THAT THEY CAN THEN.
SHOT THAT PROGRAM DOWN OR NOT
PENALIZE AT THAT PROGRAM.
I LIVE ILLICIT SELLERS.
ARV SHOULD BE SET ESPECIALLY
THEY'RE TRYING TO RUN A
STOREFRONT OR DELIVERY SUBJECT
TOO MANY LEVELS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
AND INCLUDING THE ID CHECK IF
THEY'RE TRYING TO PRETEND TO BE
A REAL SHOP AND THEY CHECK ID
BUT THEY DON'T COLLECT TAXES FOR
CALIFORNIA. TASTY SHUT DOWN WHEN
THINGS ARE PROP SIXTY FOURS IT
RAISES THE MONEY FOR ENFORCEMENT
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE KEY
FUNCTIONS AND IT'S NOT JUST LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS ALSO FISHING
GAME.
AND THE INDUSTRY TO DO WHAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED CHECK TO MAKE
SURE THE MINERS AREN'T IN THOSE
STORES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON.
THANK YOU TO A CHAIR AND.
IF I A AND I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
A LOT OF DISCUSSION I JUST ABOUT
FOR SECOND BUT I KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION OVER
THE REVENUE AND.
WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO GET
ENOUGH TO COME IN OR NOT REALLY
FOR ME THE ISSUE WAS MORE ABOUT.
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
CREATE A PATHWAY FOR THE
UNREGULATED TO GET INTO THE
REGULATED WELL FIELD AND AND FOR
ME.
IF IT MEANS REDUCING TAXES
BECAUSE THE POINT WAS MADE A
DOCTOR WITH THAT YOU MADE. THAT.
LOCALS ARE TAXING THIS AS WELL
AND IN SOME CASES EXORBITANTLY.
TO THE POINT THAT IT'S ALMOST
INCENTIVE TO NOT GET INVOLVED OR
TO NOT BE AND GET INTO THE
REGULAR A REGULATORY FIELD SO.
FOR ME IT'S ABOUT TRYING TO
INCENTIVIZE AND BRING EVERYONE
IN AND REALLY HIT THEM THE BLACK
MARKET OR THE UNDER MARKET
REALLY HARD. AND SO OF REVENUE
THAT'S ONE THING.
THAT COMES AND. MORE IMPORTANT
FOR ME IS THE SAFETY.
AND THE BIGGER THE BLACK MARKET
THE MORE YOUNG PEOPLE WE HAVE
EXPOSED.
BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT CHECKING
ID'S.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE NOT PAYING
ANY TAXES SO SOME TO ME IS
BETTER THAN NONE.
AND SO FOR ME I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THIS BILL SIMPLY FOR
THE FACT THAT IT HELPS INVITE
AND CREATE A PATHWAY FOR FOLKS
TO COME INTO THE REGULATORY. A
WORLD.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS A COMMENT
AT THIS TIME. AS SEEN NO
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COMMUNITIES AT THIS TIME.
TO THE AUTHORS SEE WISH TO
CLOSE JUST TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION YOUR
ENGAGEMENT OR QUESTIONS AND AND
DOT RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I APPRECIATE THE WORKING WITH
THE CHAMPIONS.
IF YOU CAN SEE MEMBERS LACKEY
BONTA COOLEY JOINTS OR AND
DOCTOR WOULD ARE.
LISTED AS CO AUTHORS OF THIS
MEASURE AND I.
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH YOU A MEMBERS I'D HAVE
SOME.
A SIGNIFICANT.
RESERVATIONS WITH THIS BILL
ABOVE FOR US.
BUT IT DOES ENJOY DO A PASS
RECOMMENDATION ON TELL YOU WHY
WITH HIS PERSPECTIVE SOME
RESERVATIONS THAT HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ADDRESSED BY SOME MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. THAT WE ARE
JUST SIMPLY BUT FIVE MONTHS INTO
THE LEGALIZATION OF THIS
INDUSTRY. AND OF THERE ARE A LOT
OF VARYING MOVING PIECES AND SO
IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE TAKE
ACTION TO IDENTIFY OF THE ISSUES
AT HAND IN THE INFANCY OF
RECOGNIZING THE REGULATED
MARKETPLACE WHAT CAN WE DO WHAT
MECHANISMS TO HAVE IN PLACE. A
TO GET RID OF THE BLACK MARKET A
MUCH OF THE CONVERSATION AS WE
ALL KNOW IN THE PROPOSITION WAS
A TOUTING THE.
SIGNIFICANT REVENUES COMING
FROM LEGALIZATION OF CANNABIS
AND SO THAT IS VERY COMPELLING
TO ME. AND FOR US TO THEN THINK
ABOUT ABOUT REDUCING THE TAX
RATE. WITH JUST BUT FIVE MONTHS
IN WHEN IT WAS PROPOSED TO THE
ELECTORATE A TO BE OF THIS
SIGNIFICANT REVENUE STREAM YEAH
IS A SOMEWHAT CAUSES. SOME SOME
SIGNIFICANT PAUSE.
AT THE SAME TIME. I HAVE BEEN
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH A OF THE
AUTHORS.
WITH THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
TRYING TO COME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS TO IDENTIFY THE INTENT
WHICH IS THAT OF. GETTING.
ACTORS GOOD ACTORS INTO THE
REGULATED MARKETPLACE AND HOW DO
WE IDENTIFY THAT OF THE BLACK
MARKET. A MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATION SHOULD ALSO BE WITH
RESPECT TO LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
ENSURING THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
DOES THEIR JOB. AND IT IS BEEN.
THE OBSERVATION THAT THE THERE
IT AND INADEQUATELY. EQUIPPED
AND TO DO HOMES OF THE
PRIVATIZATION AND THE REVENUES
TO ENFORCE.
IT TO THE EXTENT TO THE EXTENT
THAT THEY SHOULD.
THERE HAVE ALSO BEEN THERE'S
BEEN A COMMITMENT FROM THE
AUTHORS ON A BUDGET ASK
SPECIFICALLY WITH AYE ENGAGING
IN REQUESTING ADDITIONAL
REVENUES FOCUSED ON THAT OF LAWN
FORSMAN SO WHILE WE HAVE BEFORE
US A PIECE OF LEGISLATION THAT
IS JUST.
NARROWLY TAILORED TO THAT OF THE
INDUSTRY I KNOW THAT THERE'S A
BIG IN THAT COMMITMENTS OF FROM
INDUSTRY AND FROM AUTHORS TO
ALSO IDENTIFYING THE IMPORTANCE
OF THAT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT. OF
THE OTHER ISSUE IS THAT WITH A
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN PERMITTING
AT THERE'S ALSO BEEN ADDITIONAL
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE A
PIPELINE. A SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
OTHER INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
REGULATED MARKETPLACE.
IT SHOULD BE KNOWN. STATED
THOUGH THAT.
MEMBERS YOU SHOULD REMEMBER AND
RECALL THAT.
THE STATE DID A LOAN OF FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF PROP SIXTY FOR
CLOSE TO A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. THAT NEEDS
TO BE REPAID.
AND GIVEN THAT IT IS THE
ASSESSMENTS AND THE PROJECTIONS
THAT WE WILL BE SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDER THOSE REVENUES.
THERE'D AGAIN CREATE SOME PAUSE
WHICH IS THAT OF THE REVENUES
PROJECTED THAT WE WILL SEE AND
THAT MAY REVISED DO NOT EVEN
MEET THE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO BE REPAID.
THAT IS IS OF CONCERN. IDEA
ELLIE O. PROJECTED THAT WE SAW
THAT IN FISCAL YEAR TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN TO NINETEEN THAT WE ARE
EXPECTED TO GENERATE A HUNDRED
CENTER FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
THEN PROJECTED SIX HUNDRED AND
FORTY THREE MILLION IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR OF TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN. HOW WE ALL RIGHT TO
SPAIN THAT THERE'S NOWHERE CLOSE
NEAR TO THAT? AND SO WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE US IS A NEED FOR
CHANGE AND BECAUSE THE SYSTEM IS
NOT GOING TO WORK BUT AGAIN.
WITH RESPECT TO SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT EXISTS AT LEAST
FOR SOME PAUSE TO TRY AND
IDENTIFY. THE ISSUE AT HAND
WHICH IS THAT OF THE BLACK
MARKET OF THIS IS JUST ONE TOOL
TO ADDRESS AND ACCOMMODATE THESE
ISSUES THERE CAN BE SOME NOTED
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES THAT WE
BEST BE MINDFUL OF. WHICH IS WHY
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
ACCEPTANCE OF THE AMENDMENTS NOW
WHICH IS AGAIN TO TO RESTATE
THAT. OF THE AMEND THAT SECTION
OF THIS BILL IS TO INCLUDE
INTENT LANGUAGE STATING THAT IN
THE EVENTS THAT.
ANNUAL REVENUES FOR THE ADJUSTED
CANNABIS TAX STRUCTURE ARE
PROJECTED TO BE INSUFFICIENT TO
ADEQUATELY FUND BOTH REASONABLE
AGENCY COST AND THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. IN PROGRAM
FUNDING ENVISIONED IN PROP SIXTY
FOURTH THE LEGISLATURE SHALL
CONSIDER RESTORING.
THE ORIGINAL TAX RATE PRIOR TO
JUNE ONE TWO THOUSAND AND TWENTY
ONE SO AGAIN MEMBERS.
THERE HAS BEEN CONVERSATION
WITH RESPECT TO A RESTORING THE
ATTACKS RATING I THINK THAT'S A
REASONABLE MEASURE FOR US TO
CONSIDER AND AGAIN IT IS THE
PURVIEW OF THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO. ACCOMMODATE
AND REVISIT THIS ISSUE AT HAND
AND SO GIVEN THE RESERVATIONS
AND GIVEN SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITIES THAT I HAVE BEEN
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS AND AGAIN
THE. COMMITMENT AND THE TENACITY
OF THE AUTHORS OF THIS DOES
ENJOY AND AYE RECOMMENDATION AND
WOULD ENCOURAGE YOU ALSO TO DO
SO TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION.
AND ALSO RECOGNIZE THAT WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT A
PROPOSALS TO ADDRESS THIS OF THE
BLACK MARKET AND SO HAVING SAID
THAT.
THE MUSIC THEY WOULD YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN ACTION
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW.
LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER.
BIGGER NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
PHONE NUMBER IT GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE. OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
THAT HAS TWELVE VOTES THAT THAT
BILL IS OUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THINKING
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
MEMBERS THAT WE HAVE ESTABLISHED
A QUORUM AND SO IF YOU'LL.
AND DON'T JUST IN GOING BACK
THEN AND.
FILE ORDER.
AND WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMAN O'DONNELL. A WE NEED
A MOTION AND A SECOND.
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION.
I MISTER GIPSON A SECOND BY DR
RAM LET ME SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED SLOW AYE
LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE BLOOM.
JOHN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM.
COMING UP AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE. FONG AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I TING.
CHIU AYE.
IT YOU KNOW THE BILL IS OUT FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR FIFTY
WE NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOTION BY SUMMER GIPSON AND
DOCTOR RAMBLING AGAIN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH PRESENTER PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DAY PASSED SLOW.
I LOW AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NOW BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG NOW GIPSON.
IT'S AN AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN. IRWIN AYE MEDINA. MEDINA
AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NOW TING.
CLOSE TO THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
WE NOW MOVE ON TO A FILE ITEM
NUMBER THREE WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
BILL OF THIRTY SIXTY NINE MOTION
BY SUMMER GIPSON AS. A MOTION BY
SOME AYE GIPSON SECOND BY DOCTOR
AND LIKELY SIMPLY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED LOW
AYE LOW AYE BROWN ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
BLOOM.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I OVERLOOKED IT OBERNOLTE
AYE.
TING.
FIFTEEN.
THAT BILL IS OUT WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. OF
WHICH IS A.
.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTY
SEVEN ANY ADDITIONAL AND ON THE
THINK WE HAVE ADDITIONAL MEMBERS
TO.
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CHU. CHU AYE.
BUT A VOTE THIRTEEN ZERO.
BILL IS OUT.
THEN.
IT.
MR MEDINA WE HAVE US I.
THIRTEEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
OKAY NOW AND THEN TO.
CONSENT COUNTER FIVE OR. I'M A
FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN
THIRTY TO SIXTY ONE WE GET A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
MISTER GIBSON AT MOTIONS AND
DUCKED AROUND THE SECONDS
WE SAW YOUR PERSONAL.
MOTION IS TO PASS LOW AYE LOW
AYE BRO.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I BLOOM.
CHEN. CHEN AYE CHIU
CHIU I CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM
AYE EGGMAN.
PHONE.
FONG I GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE
IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE MEDINA. MEDINA AYE
MULLIN.
MULLIN I OVERLOOKED IT OBERNOLTE
AYE TING.
EGGMAN AYE.
FIFTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
.
AB TWO FOUR FOUR FIVE TING.
ING AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
SIXTEEN.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY MOTIONS YOU
PASS TING AYE ACTING AYE.
AB TWENTY FOUR FIFTY THIRTEEN TO
THREE.
AB THREE ZERO SIX NINE MOTIONS
YOU PASS AS AMENDED TING AYE
ACTING AYE.
A. B. THIRTY SIXTY NINE SIXTEEN
ZERO
IT'S OUT.
AB THIRTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
MOTIONS YOU PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TING NOT VOTING
TING NOBODY.
THIRTEEN ZERO.
CONSENT CALENDAR AB THIRTY TO
SIXTY ONE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TING AYE TING AYE.
SINCE
JIM IS THERE.
OKAY WE'RE ADJOURNED